star wars studios what's up what's going
on everybody
hello hello hello hello
what is up everybody
how's it going let me uh make sure hello
hello test test test yeah i think we can
hear me
star wars studios what's up what's going
on everybody
hello hello
um
mute that there we go hello
hello mr anderson the best mod in the
world what is going up
hello hello uh jett baldwin my time in
cali i literally flew in yesterday the
premiere was last night
and i flew back today
this morning um
so
it was very short-lived but it was
awesome the primer is awesome um
the newbie pro official uh i like
transformers
shangchi is awesome
for those of you asking chung cheese i
loved it i just saw it again tonight
like
four hours ago and it oh
i'm telling you guys i i really really
love shanxi
oh that's so good
it's so good it's so good it's so good i
i really really love shang chi um i'm so
tired guys
because of just everything um
but uh
i really really really
really loved the movie
um rom gamer sly they'll probably kill
gore the god butcher of the
to be honest they probably will
what chang-chi's story um well first of
all
an inbox video for the gift bag that the
game right there the shangchi gift bag i
can tell you i can show you
pretty much
so
we got a funko
i don't know if it'll zoom there you go
shaun chi funko does in the bag
here's my uh here's my pass
that i got that let me uh
that let me get around everywhere that
was my seat to watch the film
at roe p
406. um probably the coolest thing
probably the coolest thing that i have
now
and there's the bag
the [ __ ] is cool i really like the funko
he's got his staff in his hand too which
i really like
i'll just put this here
so yeah uh
that was really really cool that was
that was so cool um
how did i see it twice gabrielle um
because i got invited to the world
premiere like the red carpet one that i
post a bunch of pictures of on my
instagram and twitter
um that was the first time anybody's
ever seen it and then i also got like a
pre-screener um to see it in my home
state
so that's why
the thumbnail says episode one does it
really
oh oh i know what you're talking about
oh dang it that's annoying
yeah i'm gonna have to do that hold on
i don't know if i can do it once i'm
already live that might be that might be
a change
that might be a hard change
let's take a look see
at that
episode two should come out and i would
say like two
like 25 minutes
25 minutes
that's a rookie move on my part
episode
one uh
hey thanks gabriel
yeah t nasty nelson i saw that
it looks like she is going to be doing
some of that huh
all right let's open
where's mine there we go
yeah any clue about the credit scene uh
i mean i saw both posts pro
both post credit scenes for shanxi
and i have seen them twice now
so i really know what they are the first
one i obviously can't say spoilers
but the first one
the mid credit is
really cool
and it'll make you think it'll make you
wonder um
it it'll make you wonder
the
post credit scene after the credits uh
is pretty much a setup
for
more shangchi related things is what
i'll say
um
the first post credit scene is more of
an mcu thing and the second post credit
is a like a chongqi thing
so let's
let's figure out how to change this
thumbnail once i'm already live
because that's something i actually
haven't done before
uh
[Music]
spider-man i'm not spoiling for y'all
say i'm spoiling i literally haven't
said anything that spoiled anything calm
down um
i'm not going to do anything that's an
actual spoiler
um
hey appreciates how's it going does
abomination actually have good screen
time does he talk or is it just a little
bit um
it focuses on chongqi and his family is
what i'll say i wouldn't don't don't
really expect
things outside of that as far as like
don't expect it to be like uh
like like a multiverse of madness plot
like a bunch of different things
happening
uh it very much focuses on chiang chi
story and they do it really really well
ray shang chi out of 10 uh
i i think
i i give it a nine
um
yeah i give it a nine uh thanks so much
for that super chat
infinity shades um
i'm trying i'm just trying to try not to
actually like
give anything away right it's so hard to
say like why i loved it
and
you know things like that without really
giving away spoilers uh and i'm not
gonna give
i'm not gonna give spoilers away um
yeah
um
shanxi is in my top ten
ninja um
and
i just
i i
no it's not being too nice um
i think it was an amazing movie and i
think a lot of people are going to walk
away thinking it's amazing movie in fact
i
i
when cr when chris because i saw it with
chris tonight
when
we got done
i was like did i over hype it
and i don't care because i truly do love
the film so people can say oh you
overhyped it you did whatever that's
fine and by the way disney doesn't
pay
us to do anything right like disney's
not paying me to write a good review
that's not how it works
um
oh
what if not chunky i was about to put a
shank chi thumbnail for my watch party
episode two watch party oh come on
okay i messed up again
back to the back to the photoshop
drawing board um
uh
spoilers it's good yeah i mean the music
is really good
um
real reject
shut up don't tell them that feige
handed me a check to talk good about
movies
that's
that's confidential and you're you're in
a breach of a contract and now you're
going to jail
no that seems to be like a big thing now
it's just like all the people who get to
see
the shows and everything people are like
oh but
disney pays you all to see those good
things yeah right i wish
trust me i'd be saying a lot more better
thanks
um
yeah i never ever
ever said black widow was a top 10 movie
you were trying to put words in my mouth
and i never said that at all
never
i said black widow was a good movie
because i don't think it was as terrible
as everybody thinks it is
but never did i say it was an amazing
movie
it's fantastic it's definitely not my
top 10.
definitely not my top 10.
sorry i'm just trying to fix this
thumbnail i think i'm good now and then
i'm going to acknowledge some of the
super chats that came in
adam what's up my dude you know i can't
you know i can't tell uh 50 shades
another super chat what's up so while
you were at the premier red carpet did
you manage to learn anything about far
from home any minute any mephisto
theories for chongqing
no i wouldn't say there are i'm sure
people can
make them out of
some things that happen
hey
someone came in and donated someone oh
no my humble is not that good i'd have
to really sit there and read it but i'll
tell you what i'll take a screenshot of
it
and i'll sit down and read it
thank you so much super appreciate that
though i haven't actually read hangul in
a very long time so i'm gonna definitely
need a a refresher
uh for those of you asking today's about
t'challa uh t nasty nelson thinks the
super chat wong was in it though against
abomination yeah um and you can see that
in the trailer that's not a big spoiler
for those of you asking um how long is
it after in game
they don't say
uh for those asking this one yes uh
yeah
for this this one
it's a lot better than the first one i
would say
all right
uh
let's try this one more time episode
two
i did it i think maybe i don't know
let's try to fix this thumbnail
sorry all right now we're dang it
i'm really running on not so much sleep
right now so if i'm a little out of it i
apologize change
what if not chunky
okay
save
i wonder if it changed
sometimes takes a bit to change so let's
give it a little
a little bit to win okay
cool nope
why aren't you letting me change it it
doesn't want me to change it
up cool we're we're cool i think maybe i
don't know we'll figure it
out um is vibranium valuable in space
that's an interesting question you know
because they have like uru metal and
stuff like that in other parts of
the universe
uh
you know i don't know that's a that's a
really good question
i wonder what like captain marvel has uh
her stuff
right i wonder in
i wonder what
uru
sorry vibranium ranks in her like
her chart of
what he thinks is what what is valuable
sorry um i'm on the wrong
browser
i can't tell you guys what the post
credit scene is i'm really sorry
uh my thoughts on the moon eye costume i
actually think that looked really really
cool um i'm excited for that really i
am
let's see
does it connects to iron fist a winker
or not i'll just
say no
i'm sorry i know there were a bunch of
people hoping for that
but
thank you for that super chat to ask
that uh
frank castle what marvel property would
you like a revival for
for instance spectacular spider-man hulk
daredevil what was zack snyder directing
oh that's hard oh was zack snyder
directing
oh that's a tough one
uh
chef am thanks for that super chat
appreciate that sorry to
i i'm sure i don't think that was the
answer you wanted to hear so sorry about
that um
what marvel property frank castle
i feel like schneider would do good with
like
daredevil or punisher
and i honestly would like to see the
defenders as a group like he could
probably do that pretty well and
especially with like getting them to
come together like he did for the snyder
cut of the justice league which i loved
i uh
yeah i think
i think okay thank you i just saw
somebody say
jillian garcia
thumbnail is fixed thank you
um am i going to attend sony next week
no uh i am not
sorry
sorry sorry sorry sorry
i wish i could uh
i wish i could and like
get it get all the juicy details um
i cannot tell you about the post credit
scene guys i'm so sorry
trying to make sure
yeah um
all those are like about the
the shang chi post credit scene
um
uh one word about the post credit scene
epic you're not gonna like that but
uh
it'll it'll make you question
what it is i'll just tell you that
you're gonna
watch it and go what
you know you're going to watch them be
like what what
that's all i can say is you're just
you're going to say what so
be prepared for the theories to fly in
uh i do like the spectacular spider-man
i actually think i
um watched it not too long ago
uh
yeah
hello back to australia has
where would i rank shang chi in my
favorite marvel movies well
you know i said that uh
in my video today
i did too right my my initial reactions
when i when i like got out of the the
theater
and i was just super excited i was on
cloud nine i just went to the red carpet
premiere i just saw shanghai
like
with simileo like
like it was crazy cool like i saw
simileo kevin feige i met a lot of the
actors and stuff like that i talked to
the directors so i was really on cloud
nine
um and that was like my initial reaction
was like a really really like crazy good
movie
and then i did like my longer one where
i took some time in the hotel and i
really thought about what i saw
because i don't want to be
the guy that just hypes every movie i
want it to be genuine um
and i think that might be a little bit
what happened with black widow i
i may have said i may have made it sound
like i liked it more than i did
and if i did apologize but i didn't
think black widow was an incredible
movie i did say i thought it was a good
movie because i don't think it's a bad
movie uh i just don't think it's
super special in all honesty
um
but you know
to each their own
but this movie
crazy
good i just i don't think
i mean i watched it again and i like
kind of watched it
to to like
watch to see if it was actually as good
as i thought
and
it is
that's all i can say like
i i actually
do think
it's as good as like i hyped it up to be
um
i think it's i think it's fantastic
down to like
a lot of the details
like the music the the fighting i did
say in my video there's some parts of
like the cgi that i'm like ah that's
kind of like
you didn't really spend a lot of money
on the cgi right there you know like and
you can kind of tell but it's not on
important parts right so like i don't
care it's not on like the fighting and
stuff like that um
so i really i really don't care
hey malek you hope there's zombies live
in doctor strange multiverse and madness
that would be pretty cool i i it sounded
like multiverse madness is gonna be
pretty nuts
yeah
uh
yeah so
my favorite mcu movie of all time
oh hi marina sorry i don't mean to i
don't want to miss your super chat there
uh hello can't save a whole show but
best from sydney australia hey
dang we yeah we're on different time
zones there huh thanks for stopping by
thanks so much for that super chat i
hope you and uh hope you enjoyed this
episode of what if uh for those asking i
i definitely consider this episode of
what if better than the next one or the
last one sorry and i haven't like
decided if i like the third episode
better than the second episode
this is the
this is the t'challa
episode
so it hits differently because it's his
last performance you know what i mean
so
i haven't decided
um this one's cool
this is really it's a cool episode and
um
i do like what if i just really wish it
was live action but i enjoy it i i super
enjoyed it super enjoy super enjoy
so
sorry i really can't give you guys a
hint of what the credit scenes is about
guys i really can't yeah i don't know if
you guys realize but like when we see
these movies and stuff like we have
contracts we signed and stuff like that
um
so
um
soup spoiled the post credits saying
well
i'm not gonna do that
any spider-man no way home leagues i see
a few people asking no guys i think
we're just
i think we're just waiting for
is it
next monday i think is the date cinema
con
yeah next days
cinemacon uh
does what if have a post credit scene uh
i haven't i didn't see any uh to my
knowledge i don't really think
i don't really think there was one in
the first three
uh because they don't connect
um
you know
they've been kind of uh
blatant about that they're they're
separate um
so yeah
they don't connect so
is shangchi ragnarok or winter soldier
level i personally think so uh i'm
sticking with my nine out of ten
and
i i can't tell you why i don't give it a
10 out of 10 because i don't want to
talk about the movie to spoil it
i feel like if there was five minutes of
just if i had one scene that was five
minutes longer
and focused on
i could probably give it a 10 out of 10
or a 9.5 out of 10. um
because some parts of cgi is kind of
like
you're like ha you can tell that cgi but
again like the fighting and everything
i was so worried that it was going to be
more marvel than kung fu
but they blended it really really well
they they blended it like super super
well
um
what would your what if be about
maybe like what if i was a
mainly a dc youtuber instead of a marvel
youtuber maybe what if i was a star wars
youtuber instead of a
a marvelous youtuber that's funny
um
it's kind of top no it it's top 10 for
me it's 100
it's 100
in my top
five
favorite marvel movies and but
i don't count
uh
i don't count avengers infinity war or
avengers in game when i do that because
like
to me it's a little different those are
these huge movies that were built up
over 10 years right and it's a part one
and a part two essentially
so i don't really count those
when we talk about like what my favorite
movie is
so
but even even if i do count those it's
still top five for me ragnarok's my
favorite
oh that's hard to say maybe if the very
first avengers film is my favorite
and then ragnarok
it's really cool it's like super super
cool uh yeah the shangchi trailer is
thursday i've been told not uh
not tomorrow wait today's today's
tuesday night
yeah
what if forum was dc wonder that's funny
uh rank time machine chi ooh uh i don't
know because i watched it in the theater
i didn't watch it like on my um
the way that they normally send it to us
that has the runtime i'd say like two
hours
um
yeah i don't know
dc wonder
that's
mcu tier list yeah
i could i could do that
guys if you spam you're gonna get timed
out
avengers 3 is your favorite movie
so infinity war
is that what you're referring to
when i go to the world premiere why
didn't i ask kevin feige or a marvel
worker when they're gonna drop the
trailer uh
because that's unprofessional
and i wouldn't get invited back if i did
that all right
episode two
what if t'challa became
a star-lord does that say became a
star-lord it does say became a star-lord
so
i'm ready to go
i've got it pulled up here
that's not it ignore that gotta put up
here i'm not gonna be able to show as
much because these videos are getting
copyrighted because i'm not allowed to
show the footage and i kind of am
but we are going to start right now
three two
one
go
and here we are
let's go full screen
i enjoyed this episode it's 35 minutes
long
and i'm hoping everybody else enjoys it
too
which way i gotta scoot this way there
we go
that's just the intro so
uh i hope we can expect a a teaser
this month i
i
i really don't know what they're doing
with this trailer at this point time
guys my trailer guy hasn't told me
anything
it really hasn't told me anything all
right
we start
we're starting right now
time
good the thumbnail did change sweet
oops
yes i did enjoy
yesterday's premiere movie world it was
pretty cool
probably the best experience of my life
outside of like personal family things
what if
i can't spoil shake you guys all right
what if it's starting we're gonna enjoy
this episode the t'challa episode
because it's pretty great
there he is
is your destiny determined by your
nature or the nature of your world it's
a good thing to think about
like what if you were born
in a different country than the one you
were born in right would you still be
the same person or would your
the nature of your behavior be different
okay
boom
he knows him
thank you regas
this is the star lord
[Laughter]
uh yes go see
in theaters for sure
my boss
super separate
the honor of my life to spar with you
should i not use
i love this oh it's such a good
storyline
ready
he still has the necklace which is
interesting
classic star-lord
[Laughter]
that's great
no don't put spoilers in the chat guys
let's let's try not to ruin it for some
other people some people don't like
spoilers
i have hired worse it takes him
hello simply steve
he hunted me too
i speak a little dutch it's breaking the
base you need allowance
i know it's cool how he's a fanboy of
him
star-lord
and yondu
what up
no wonder that killed off yondu he's
like super freaking op man that arrow is
crazy
cj is bet if you have like an instagram
and you want to post it on and people
want to go look at the
uh thing on your instagram you can post
it in the comments
for those in india i just keep uh keep
refreshing because it is out
it is out out out
the watcher
1988
his dad's a lot more buff
in the animated series
rate change she and 5 stars 4.5
i give it a 9 out of 10 4.5 out of 5.
you let him suffer there you go
that's funny cj
and then
just
threw it out
wow
look at the watch in the background
and there it is
they were arriving to
abduct the spawn of celestial ego oh
that looks so cool
that's not him
what's up pranav how's it going
it's taser face
uh i give shang chi
4.5 stars i give it a 9 out of 10. i
really really really enjoyed the movie
and now he's with 20 years later and now
he's famous star-lord
look at this guy
that random tire it's funny because i
was i watched the premiere with john
campia he was sitting like two seats
down for me
you could say what your favorite heist
is
so julian he said they were in wakanda
because they picked up like a huge
cosmic
um energy reading which they thought
would be him because he's a cosmic
entity but it was actually
the vibranium in wakanda that they
picked up on accident
yeah
look who it is
i love this
pretty sure it's just genocide and i'm
pretty sure it's efficient i love this
twist that freaking t'challa star-lord
is such a good guy
that he changed thanos's mind
you are the
star-lord
yeah no problem for explaining
let us take a bit see look isn't that so
cool he said his wife and daughter are
still alive
that's because t'challa freaking talk
thanos out of killing everybody and look
who it freaking is
yeah
she calls him cha-cha i love it
yep thanos is just chill yeah chill now
now
look at like a good
like in a more emotional nebula
because thanos was turned good by
t'challa
is a cool thing to think about
and now
they definitely like each other
uh
i
think josh brolin is voicing dennis
maybe not not to listen more carefully
captain genocide
yep the collector
i think it's josh brolin that's uh
that's voicing him uh it is an energy
drink that i'm drinking
it's so funny that they kind of fear the
collector more than thanos it's
interesting huh
what if right
i know mr anderson right it's so cool
how he affects how he changes the
universe and it's such a perfect
it's perfect like tribute to chadwick
sorry it's not out in india guys
hopefully it gets out soon
yeah it's a cool episode
nowhere
there they are
so the collector is the black order it's
so funny
look it is
the black order proxima midnight
call me captain genocide again
[Laughter]
corvus glaive
a perfect plan
uh just ask if you want to ask
oh yeah dude richard i freaking i'm so
stoked for black adam and i even got a
mana shirt underneath
the collectors like this huge buff
king now the
of the universe
you don't get what's going on
um
i'll explain after
basically thanos was talked into being
good
by t'challa as star-lord
so the collector look it's howard the
duck
uh sorry cromwell i don't even know if
i'm invited to the premiere yet i think
i am but
no the collector's being played by
benicio they he was accredited in the
beginning
hello hello hello oh super stuck for
eternals
eternals or the ravagers fighting
this is a good episode i like this
episode
the flashy
flash it's howard the duck
who's the best hand-to-hand combat
character in the mcu it's definitely
shanghi after you see that you'll see
why it's
it's awesome
look his necklace activated uh wakandan
ship
spacecraft
how cool that is
this is cool
was abducted
uh the name of the episode
what if t'challa was a star-lord i think
it's time for one of your great escapes
oh
oh no
here we go
look he's in a box
the collector has him
freaking he's like ripped
hmm
dissect him
and strip his remains for parts
to my best friend t'challa
guess what dead
cha-cha i love how she calls him cha-cha
dan i was just so freaking big
it's awesome
smile on the face
cha-cha love it
yeah sam jerico it's pretty cool
hey hey hey
look who's out
but ebony mars telekinesis so you know
but look who saves the day
it's partially audible when i'm silent
oh that's not good
not sure how to
stop that
yeah thanos is a good guy and it's
really cool
i really like this episode
this is pretty cool
yeah
he's got it almost looks like the things
arm
but it's not like
orange
look how freaking big this collector is
freaking
i guess when you want to look he's got
the shield and thor's hammer
oh
[Music]
that woman has taste necro sword
that's super cool i love that
and he takes it from him but he takes it
back
isn't that cool
uh i have watched episode three already
yes
oh was that korg's arm oh good point
damian
that might have been korg's arm
mad
mad titan not crazy mad
i love good thanos
it's so cool
but approximate midnight comes up
look at this guy man
oh
what the arrow
he calls him his kid i love it
oh he catches it
meanwhile in the world of thanos getting
his butt kicked which you actually feel
sad about because he's good
uh yeah it's josh oh i don't i don't
know for sure but it certainly does
sound like it's just brilliant than us
his daughter comes to save the day
take your daughter and run thanos i love
it i love that
he's good i love it it's so cool
and that like
he didn't torture nebula because thanos
or thanos just t'challa changed him
no ice kick his butt
or not or just get your butt kicked
sticky fingers
sticky fingers
guess what
sucka and boom
and look who he gives it to
he
guess what she does oh everybody's out
oh
oh karma
that's what you get for collecting
people dissecting them and caging them
douche
and he escapes in his wakandan
aircraft from nowhere
dope
she calls them cha-cha and i love it i i
hope they're together
and look who the look who
[Music]
yeah richard b isn't that funny
it's a it's a funny meme
i laughed so hard when i saw it
i'm blowing to them oh you know what
it's probably my fan i'm sorry sorry
guys i didn't realize i was in your
ear the whole time
it's 1 19 a.m for me
i'm mountain time
guess what he's gonna go back
to his home
with thanos not there to destroy it
that's cool that's cool scene
and he's home
bye-bye
look
that sounds a lot like genocide
no because it's random
inefficient
nebulosa dead
hahaha
and look who it is
what would star-lord himself be up to
i'm there popping joe
can't spare a little time
for dear old dad
that might
freaking the collector says that might
start the end of the world but that's a
story for another day so i'm pretty sure
oh this is this nice
isn't that cool
well
rob if that's how you pronounce your
name uh
connected to the real story isn't like
the mcu
or like what if because what if doesn't
really have like a connected story all
the episodes are going to be different
oh i know isn't that sad guys like
it is sad right like because chadwick
but like isn't this such a cool way
to remember him
based on the story from marvel comics
all right hold on i want to see some of
the wait stop no go back
freeze i was so close
go back 10 seconds hold on let's take a
look at some of the uh
the cast
hearts for chadwick i like that dr drake
wait
dr drake ramore from friends that's
awesome i love that
it's portuguese
all right let's take a look at this
oh nope sorry that is not uh
the cast list yet one second let's uh
let's take a look
nope still not the cast hold on
did i miss it
did i miss the castle i don't think i
did
give it a second
nope that's not it either jeez
how you doing
i love friends that's such a good one
yes please tell them mr anderson i i
haven't heard anything about no way home
guys the last thing i heard cinemacon
they might show it
that's all i got
ytp yeah i'm not sony
i'm so confused they didn't
did i miss it
where was the actual like voiceover
castings
that's not it
cast gosh i knew i it was there okay
jeffrey white's watcher chadwick boseman
karen gillan michael rooker
jamon
hansell
t'chaka john connie thanos jasper allen
it was jess brown the collector was
benicio ego was kurt russell craglin was
sean gunn taserface chris sullivan i'm
not actually sure if that's the actual
person actor that is howard the duck
with seth green what's she new okoye
deny guerrera
karina ophelia levy bond
uh and i'm not sure
[Music]
tom
the han lawyer was up anymore in the
movies and i'm not sure about the rest
of them
not sure about the rest of them
oh man
uh so all right guys
thoughts
i i like this
better than the first
uh for sure
i think it was a really great way to
remember chadwick this episode is about
him affecting the universe
instead of the universe affecting him
and i think that was really cool where
the heck is my discord
discord like
uninstalled itself
there it is
yeah well ch chill mike i mean it pretty
much said like yes probably in the world
right
it's a christopher
i don't hear the christopher
christopher
oh you know what hold on i think i know
i don't hear the christopher are you
there christopher
nope i don't hear you at all
are you muted
i'm trying to talk i hear you now oh
there we go okay there we go yeah
hold on reference
todd andrew
thanks for super chat i want to see this
version of thanos in live action yeah
isn't it so cool
i like this episode a lot because one
it's a good tribute to chadwick and two
right and it but it really does
offer like like the first episode was
like
you know what if
you know but the story kind of was the
same because they still went on to fight
hydra and stuff like that you know what
i mean i like red skulls
this one this one's like you know what
if t'challa became star-lord like the
universe like completely changes
and that's why i like it because so many
of like thanos is good all because
t'challa
had a good stern talking with him and
that's what i was literally just
how chad vic bozeman is that though like
every account we've ever heard about him
as a person was his power when he spoke
and his care for others and
that power was really demonstrated in
this episode as we saw him just go and
touch so many lives in the universe and
that was super cool to see right
everybody
like you said he's ever had anything to
say about chadwick just says he's like
the best guy ever and this is cool this
is cool because
he
instead of the universe changing him
instead of your surroundings like
changing you which happens a lot to
people in life
he changed them he literally convinced
thanos
just by talking just by talking to him
and in return what happens
like all of a sudden nebula is not
completely torn apart because he doesn't
do that to her right and we don't know
what happened to gamora they don't say
that but
you know yondu has t'challa and then
everybody knows who he is the star-lord
because he still goes about doing good
yeah wherever he is whatever situation
he's in
it's it's super cool to see that impact
and that that power that he has and it
is kind of sad that we won't be able to
see that further on in the mcu
yeah it's
it is sad that he's gone uh
this is good though like our final
chance to hear his voice
in such a
in such a positive way
and you know what's really like honestly
like
super
sad to think about is that
he had cancer like during this whole
thing the whole thing and no one knew
about it
and that says a lot about your character
to try to tough that out yourself and
and not beat it yeah and but not to like
worry other people and to still like do
your job
and do it well
granted i you know i think
you know they said that he thought i was
to beat it which is also sad but i mean
that's the attitude you have to have
when you have cancer yeah yeah and it
was it was um
i almost been the writers or the
directors that said that chadwick was
the first one to sign up for what if
yeah it was it was the director
hey isaiah richardson how's it going
thanks for another super chat
uh i think we just got proof that what
episodes will connect down the line we
know t'challa is in four episodes but
also the scene with ego and quill
previews another episode of same
universe so
thank you for that super chat first of
all and to that point
you know what was it in a
was it like a hyundai commercial or
something that what if
that marvel did like a what if hyundai
commercial or something some car company
i missed it
yeah you can find it online
but
it showed like a like some footage
of like
characters from different universes
popping up
and fighting together so
i'm kind of thinking like there might
actually be
a final episode right where it's like
you were saying that before we went live
today yeah yeah i think there might be
like a episode where these worlds kind
of do collide like
because remember
marvel
i was gonna say marvel doesn't lie
marvel doesn't
lie for the sake of lying they do it to
throw us off you know they do it
out of good
will good good intentions right because
i know a lot of people like spoilers mr
anderson i know you i know you love
sports
uh mr anderson since he is my mod is
privy to all the spoilers that i get
above before time so when we talk
personally he uh i know he likes
spoilers i personally
it's my job to know spoilers but i would
rather not know them but of course i
actually never watched trailers i
actually one of my favorite things in
the world is watching trailers
i it it gets me emotional the music and
everything how they set it up like the
way like they set them like the first
avengers trailer is like
for the first of interest
but anyways can we talk about how cool
it was to see a reformed thanos i loved
it i love so much fun to see him
fighting alongside people we know and
love and and everybody that keeps making
fun of him for thinking captain aside
might i add efficient
genocide to me i love that that was
really fun to see i wish we could see
something like that i don't know what if
like from this perspective that we got
to see and i think you hit it on the
head the first one was kind of like
following the story yeah from this
perspective where you get to see these
other characters who've played big huge
medicine roles or different roles in
this different light
where you can kind of compare and
contrast to what we saw versus what
they're giving us that's a lot of fun
it's a lot of fun i gotta i think your
dad might be in my check we got a mic
mike russ or yeah yeah he's in my
teacher hey
how's it going
uh thanos fighting bud
you know
i liked that
it was like the collector becomes this
big powerful person but he like took the
first order
yeah that was crazy black order they
called them the black order no it's the
black order sorry first order
uh didn't they change the name in
infinity war
no they were all called call obsidian i
believe
no cop city and was the big dude oh yeah
but they changed no they changed
they called them something they called
it
i can't chat help me out here i'm
getting it confused because yeah
call obsidian they changed the name of
the big guy to coal obsidian
no i think they changed the name of the
group to call obsidian
hmm yeah
someone help me out
uh bryce
carabello thank you so much for super
chat
the one thing about this episode that i
don't necessarily like is i'm confused
why does charlotte go by star-lord
that's why peter's mob called him
uh
fair point black order they called them
the black corner in the movie that's
what i that's what i was saying but in
the comics i believe they're called coal
obsidian
they changed a name from the comics and
it's been such a long time since we
talked about this that
that's why i'm like
yeah
it i i believe the name in the comics
was called obsidian like the group of
them was called call obsidian like
children of thanos
yeah yeah yeah yeah because cole
obsidian the actual like that guy i
think you know
him in the dwarf yeah his name in the
comics was black door for me so they
changed his name
i didn't think they called them the
black order i think they called them the
children of thanos it was children of
thanos but i think they were also the
cool obsidian
old city was a member of
the of the group
that's what they called black um
oh right they left out a children of
thanos yeah they left i remember that uh
it's been too long since my [ __ ] game
dang it it's been a while since i read
those comics pirate man thank you for
that super chat i want to know how the
collector got cap shield and hell's head
i know right um
it's amazing what
thanos not
not
going on to kill half of the universe
made such a crazy effect like it put the
collector in power
like that and that's that power
everything and it changed everything you
know thanos has that power and then all
of a sudden
you know but bryce that that that's a
good point
um but the episode is called
what if
t'challa became
a a star-lord i noticed that too i was
like interesting but you do make a good
point with what his mom called him
but maybe
i don't know
he said it's a nickname and he didn't he
say like at one point he doesn't even
necessarily like it
cha-cha cha-cha i love
i love chuck i love
that's the whole point right what if
maxwell thanks for joining but pirate
man i you know i ha i have that
that that's a question too right did he
kill captain america and thor like
hella like how did he get
how did he get their stuff you know do
it do we know
um no i'm hoping to see a few more
episodes with this kind of um
cool
eyeglass view of what things could have
been
and you could really imagine a world
where thanos was just some cool dude and
that's where the universe was almost
more connected because of one person
right
nice jake thanks for the love the nebula
t'challa couple shoes
said love you chris love your chat hope
you have a good night watch marvel shh
what marvel show should i watch to go to
sleep loki
loki uh deadly black whole episode three
is not about zombies i have seen episode
three i promise you that's not what it's
about i won't say what it's about to
spoil it for the people who don't want
to know
but it's not about zombies it's not the
zombie one
there zombie one will come and it's
gonna be liddy yeah hey thanks for
another super chat is there richardson
great to see a powerful collector
he has powers yeah um
it's like the collector right i mean
this was cool he's like super jacked and
he's like you know he's ripped and he's
kind of all-powerful until they did
sticky fingers
right it's like
well let's do get help i don't want to
do get help it's like sticky fingers
yeah
who's doing it you because you lied to
me
it was pretty cool there were a ton of
fun references in easter eggs captain
america's shield
um all sorts of different little things
they put in there this episode was
really jam-packed with fun little
marvel
marvel peer throughs yeah uh hello there
you are correct
to answer your question
partially
um
again i go back to
this is really cool because
we no longer have chadwick
but everybody who said anything about
him had nothing but good things to say
and it sounds like he kind of did change
people and this episode is about
t'challa like changing the universe
so i think it's very fitting for the
last marvel
project that we get from him because
i heard some people asking if it really
was
uh
him voicing a chat but yes it was the
last thing he did
so
i think it's really cool
super super cool
i
i see some people who are i think most
people like the episode but go ahead and
drop it in the comments guys what did
you think
what would you rate it from one to ten
what would you rate this episode i
definitely think it's better than one
i just one of the three we saw was my
favorite
rk dennis was the mvp in this one
i know swats
i think other than than star-lord
yeah yeah should i kneel would you like
that was a fun reference too
we don't do that here should i be
kneeling
that part was funny he was like that was
hilarious that whole character was
hilarious yeah he was really good he he
punches like the you know electricity
thing classic star-lord right before he
falls in the ground and faints like
so funny
oh
harder and faster alex wilson throws an
11 out there
it really did have that essence of how
so did
pengutaku
i'll get some eights elevens a
ten ten
first one was a six this one was an
eight eight nine ten six
seven
yes get in
on them star wars cantina bar that's
funny how when disney owns things you
can
just cross them off
um
cosmetics
got a 9.6 out of 10 over here nice
what's why why not what where yeah what
what were your miners
all right so you're minus what was your
minus point four what what made you lose
those twenty out of ten mustafa twenty
out of ten that's uh
lots of nines going on there
yeah
yeah a lot of people are excited that
they saw cosmo uh the dog at the end
there wasn't there wasn't much you could
really
be disappointed about this episode
out of 10 on my from madison
i mean
i think
you have to view these shows for what
they are like i don't typically like
animation um
there is animation that i like there are
shows that are animated that i like but
i i always prefer live action
but like i'm not i'm trying not to let
that like
affect my viewing for these for the
series because i have to appreciate what
it is like in the first episode i
actually appreciated
some of the things that captain carter
could do because it's animated right and
the animation style is really good like
i got to give it to the people doing the
animation of the style yeah it's it's
really good right so
i appreciate the first episode the like
combat throwing the shield and
everything that captain carter did
because it's just not something that you
would get
live action and if you did i don't think
it would be very well done
yeah um
but this story was more fun to follow
this story is fun the story is fun um i
think people are gonna be
intrigued by episode three it's a dark
it's it's dark it's a little it's a
little dark um
it's a little dark
so
uh yeah uh cody edmondson a lot someone
mentioned that in the beginning was that
korg's hand that the collector had and i
i'm wondering if it was
i actually saw that and i was like what
was that in your hand
joe's rock
yeah right hey what's going on that's my
that's my arm can i have it back
i needed to hang out with deadpool this
is a joke for you
no need to be scared unless you made a
paper right
but uh now overall super fun it's nice
that they're giving us a little
something to hold us over and that's the
fun of disney plus
how much
projects and material we're getting from
so much
and each one you can see the time the
effort and the thought they put into
this episode it wasn't just thrown
together slapped together and they do
that with every minute of anything
marvel that ever gets broadcasted
anywhere in the world
yeah so a lot of fun i think i said this
last week
we were getting three movies a year
before
yeah i think three was what we were
getting for maybe four sometimes and now
we have what like three four
five movies and three projects
like three four or five
disney plus shows right depending on
miss marvel and hawkeye right i mean
right right right and then four movies
like
we're getting a ton of stuff these
movies coming out this year are all
going to be big boy movies
yeah oh i think i'm cute shabbat thank
you they're going all out on these
movies it's pretty crazy
hannibal collector
yeah yeah
the problem all right we finally got an
answer for where the point four went
okay the problem is with the animation
as warren said sometimes to me it feels
while they are speaking it becomes a
little weird i guess means a little
unnatural would be a 10 if they were
improved so the voice dubbing didn't
necessarily match well and i think
there's this point for and some actors
aren't used to it and
as somebody who does voice overs for
things
trust me when i started
don't go watch my first videos everybody
go watch like the first time
[Music]
anymore
it's like sexy whispering into them
pretty much
but um if you go and look on my tick
tock actually i posted cosmic culture on
tik tok the uh sebastian stan
doing his voice over and he was
struggling he was struggling it was
hilarious he was like in a closet or
something too right he's like yeah he's
like a tiny little booth he's just like
if you think this is good
it was hilarious to watch but thanks for
sharing zakiyah thank you for uh thank
you very much so did
what if i get invited to the eternals
premiere uh so i i talked to like my
contacts at marvel on disney after on
the red carpet literally on the red
carpet
and um
he said that he was gonna invite me to
the next one and the next one's eternal
so i think i might be in i got a super
chat from jd ultra thanks so much
i wish he would have trans
transferred me to the black panther for
one last time what did oh like turned
into him uh because that wasn't the
story right it was him he never actually
got that part yeah he uh
had to do the heart-shaped herb and
everything like that technically his
father was
you know black panther probably that as
well yeah he never got to that point
yeah but thanks about super chat that's
a question um
you know what i
you know we're getting the killmonger
episode with tony stark that's what i'm
really excited for i think that'll be a
very fun one yes and
man i really am wondering if
everything's just going to collide at
the end
but if it's like a mini secret wars they
all collapse into one universe and they
fight together
ego is trying to take over that's what i
was thinking maybe we get like a tiny
secret uh secret wars yeah and uh it all
kind of builds up that definitely was
like kind of like a cliffhanger with ego
wouldn't it
yeah but i like how the collectors like
and this might you know be the end of
the world
because ego gonna capture star-lord and
he's alone he has nobody to like
stop no one to help him right he doesn't
have the guardians it's just star-lord
who doesn't know anything
and he's ego's just gonna grab him and
then go okay here's my power source die
world like it's all me
so that's probably in the universe right
there's kind of what he was saying he's
like but that's a story for another time
it's like i think the story is pretty
clear he go takes over everything
you mean like the last episode yeah
what if warren gets access to spiderman
no way home trailer don't early access i
don't think that's gonna happen i really
don't think it's gonna happen yeah i've
never got like a trailer before
it's only like you know the episodes in
the movies um
never got a trailer before that's not a
that's not a thing sadly
i wish it were a thing but it's not all
right guys i
i just flew in from l.a today i have
zero sleep i'm just gonna let you guys
know ahead of time
don't expect to break down in the
morning um if i do a breakdown it's
gonna be
in the afternoon because i need some
sleep um
but the premiere was awesome and thank
you guys for supporting me to get to
this part so hopefully i can continue to
you know see all these movies and
everything ahead of time and give you
like little tidbits here and there
without spoiling too much and getting
you know sued by disney but
there you go guys
thank you to everybody who joined and uh
watched
uh super eclipse entertainment no not
not only people from us get early access
uh because i know my butt heavy or paul
over at heavy spoilers he gets early
access but like the world premieres are
always in the us
the very first one i know there are
premiers over in the uk and other parts
of the world
um
and i don't know if he went to those
because they haven't been doing them
like the past year and a half but i know
he gets early access so
yeah
dean astin nelson thanks for the super
chat these disney plus shows nerf
characters so hard thanos and loki
uh well hopefully in season two loki is
freaking insane
and uh yeah for the animated thanos i
think they just did it for the story you
know
so
but all right guys i'm gonna let's end
the super chats now because i'm getting
off because as you can see i'm very
tired it is bedtime he's very tired i
woke up very early to catch my flight
home here after sleeping only about four
hours
and then when we got here it was
alicat's birthday so we went to eat and
then we went to see shangji again
and then we came here and we went live
so
uh busy boy day yeah
yeah
um so yeah but hey thanks everyone in
the chat
um i love you all i love everybody if
you're even if you're not chatting
you're just watching thanks for joining
super appreciate you uh appreciate
everybody that also goes over to chris's
channel cosmic culture and checks that's
mine he's actually in the room
right next to me we are that door we are
roommates
look i i conveniently dropped a link for
you guys too oh wow convenient chris
chris
everybody go check chris out give him a
follow he does awesome content like i do
uh many edits for cosmic wonder
so
uh expect a video tomorrow but i don't
know what i'm gonna be because i'm just
gonna wake up when i wake up tomorrow in
all honesty so expect a a video in the
afternoon
not in the morning not my typical
breakdown we'll get back to that uh next
week but i'm just too tired i gotta
i have to i have to rest
so hey i love you all mr anderson thank
you so much for being the best mod uh
we'll talk tomorrow i'll give you some
chunky spoilers
um
and yes thank you to everybody who super
chatted regular cheddar just watched in
the background just stopped by for a
brief moment and left everybody we we
super appreciate you you're why we do
this we keep it going we love you all
and we'll